[Musique]
monsanto a payé plus de 289 millions de
dollars un jardinier américain atteint
d'un cancer
c'est bien sûr inédit est ce que je fous
rires ils ont 10 probablement pas mais
oui ça va tuer quelqu'un c'est lourd et
chaque fois que ça revienne je me
demande pourquoi moi extrait de
l'émission enquête diffusée cette
semaine qui portait sur les risques pour
la santé humaine des herbicides à base
de glyphosate sujet que plusieurs
émissions à bord et sur nos ondes cette
semaine la semaine verte l'épicerie mais
en plus cette semaine ya une importante
étude scientifique qui a montré qu'il ya
bien un lien entre l'exposition à ces
paires by side et aux types de cancer on
en parle à notre chronique scientifique
avec renault wenger a gagné bonjour un
héros joe d'abord qu'est-ce que cette
étude montre exactement mais elle est
importante parce que ces méta analyse
que montrer chez l'humain un lien entre
une exposition à de forts taux de glaise
et d'herbicides à base de glyphosate et
une hausse du risque de développer un
cancer du sang qu'on appelle le lymphome
non-hodgkinien ceci le même cancer que
celui qui touchait les personnes qui ont
témoigné dans les émissions enquête par
exemple cette semaine et ces travaux
viennent de chercheurs américains de
l'université de washington qui ont
regroupé des études qui avait déjà été
fait sur les effets du glyphosate sur la
santé humaine et ça ça leur a permis de
travailler avec un bassin de 65000
personnes qui venaient du canada des
états unis et de l'europe et de 6 des
personnes qui ont été suivis pendant
plusieurs années des fois même des
décennies
est ce que les chercheurs ont remarqué
c'est qu'en regardant les personnes qui
étaient les plus exposées au glyphosate
on avait une hausse du risque de
développer un lymphome de hodgkin y est
de 41 pour ça et ça on veut dire quoi
exactement par hausse de risques ça faut
mettre ce chiffre en contexte au canada
en lymphome de hodgkin issa représentent
environ 5% de tous les nouveaux concerts
qui arrive à ces achats chaque année
c'est le temps je pense et le cinquième
en importance qu'on retrouve au pays
mais à l'échelle d'une vie mais risque
que moi j'ai par exemple de développer
ce cancer c'est 2% donc une hausse de
risque de 41% si je travaillais avec une
énorme quand il y faisait ça ferait
passer mes chances de développer ce
cancer là à 3% et sur cette hausse
on la retrouve
uniquement chez des personnes qui
étaient chez les gens dans la population
qui ont été les plus exposées au
glyphosate pour la population en général
cette étude ne devrait pas être très
inquiétante mais pour les personnes qui
travaillent dans monde agricole ou qui
sont ou qui travaillent avec des
herbicides à base de glyphosate tout ça
devrait lever un drapeau rouge parce
qu'en terme épidémiologique une hausse
de 41% ça reste un chiffre assez gros et
il faut rappeler que les herbicides à
base de glyphosate c'est parmi les plus
utilisés au monde n'ont au final ça peut
donner beaucoup de cancers ces données
ont tout de suite bien sûr été contestée
par bio la compagnie qui racheter
monsanto mais elles viennent rajouter
justement des éléments plus à la
controverse scientifique que lui en ce
moment pour ce qui est des herbicides à
base de glyphosate
oui parce que renault il faut dire que
les risques du cliff hosatte c'est un
sujet très controversé en sciences on
l'a vu dans les dernières semaines
effectivement il ya beaucoup d'études
qui disent que se produit le plus de
données le cancer d'autres non en 2015
le produit a été étiqueté comme
cancérigène par le centre international
de recherche sur le cancer
mais l'autre côté plusieurs agences
nationales qui vont conclure que c'est
un produit sécuritaire est la différence
entre ces deux ces deux décisions là ça
peut provenir de la source d après
remonter jusqu'à la source des données
que eux ont utilisé parce qu'un peu plus
tôt cette semaine
il ya une étude qui était présenté dans
un reportage à l'émission les années
lumière qui montre que lors de
l'évaluation des risques 99% des études
qui viennent fabricants vont dire que
les produits à base de glyphosate de son
sans risque alors que 70% des études qui
ont été publiés dans des revues
scientifiques révisé par les pairs elles
disent que ça peut avoir un lien avec le
cancer
donc c'est sûr que c'est pas toutes les
études indépendantes qui sont bonnes
ni toutes les études de l'industrie qui
sont problématiques mais quand on voit
ce genre d'opposition là on peut se
poser des questions plus en plus avec le
reportage de l'émission enquête on
voyait que certaines études
indépendantes avaient été modifiées par
des employés de monsanto
mais là on a vraiment un problème de
conseils de confiance ans et voilà c'est
ça on se demande qui croient que ces
études auxquelles on peut faire
confiance
avec cette incertitude là qu'est ce
qu'on fait ce que est ce qu'on devrait
pas adopté un principe de précaution
ça c'est ce que beaucoup de chercheurs
suggèrent ses soucis de santé canada
réitère que pas de danger aux taux
actuels d'exposition et ont renouvelé
son utilisation pour 15 ans
mais en europe on a renouvelé son
utilisation pour seulement 5 ans et si
on parle d'alimentation mais ça c'est
des normes qui varient non seulement
d'olive aliments par aliments mais elles
sont pas les mains aussi en europe au
canada et aux états unis donc et tout
site où cette espèce de mélange là c'est
parce que c'est très difficile d'évaluer
les seuils d'exposition sécuritaire à
ces produits donc le meilleur moyen de
s'en sortir c'est d'accélérer la
recherche qui est fait de façon encadrée
quand même temps de développer des
solutions de rechange pour l'industrie
agricole
je rappelle que votre chronique comme
tous les samedis on peut la revoir sur
la page facebook de l'audimat et merci
beaucoup renovables et à bientôt